welcome to this video playing civ on Tia
Santa John German flag German name mmm I
have the feeling I know this guy stop
playing 2nd bundesliga so pretty decent
decent over the ball player seems to
only 21 rated nyah nyah German 340 well
let's see we have got a queen's gambit
accepted and in fact them it's quite
funny that that it's a five-minute game
i wanted to play a 15-minute game but I
accidentally hit the five-minute button
ok i am want to prevent Bishop g4 here
not sure if I need to but it seems it
seems decent in this type of position
black very often place with knight c6
yeah and you did with 96 mm-hmm h6
sometimes you have ideas like Queen d3
Bishop h6 but it's just preventing that
hmm don't know my maybe maybe plane on
my booth and we need to sneeze I had
target turn the audio down I hope your
ears didn't fall off I hope I could I
could stop could stop it from getting
onto the video rook e8 yeah this is
really nothing in this position right
hmm ok now I've took one to exchange
even more pieces and now he's trying to
sec on edge shreya that's not fair and
maybe that's even working hmm
okay idea life looks looks g5 looks
crazy I don't really want to do that
yes no maybe I don't I don't really see
a good plan here and i want i do really
don't want him to take on a ch3 this can
get get dangerous quickly this is why i
want to trade off some pieces if it
takes on the phone or which i think you
will thus at least should should be
quite ok it's some nothing special at
all but I'm not in trouble how to how to
play again
I don't really have a have an idea in
this position how to how to improve I
mean the bishop or nay to is not
especially great yeah maybe he's got c6
at some point possible it's not it's not
bleeding to trouble though everything
else fails I can always play a black
Queen v6 twin a seven or something like
that yeah however it's it's just it's
just nothing going on in terms of me
doing something okay taking a five
if it takes on d5 I can take here right
Knight takes Queen f5 at least then this
isn't this isn't so easy now I'm
threatening to threatening various
things here since probably a good
defense but still now I have the bishop
against tonight this is something i can
take here playbook head is there a trick
rookie Eddie can go King King g7 Quincy
3 check this isn't this winning at the
end it often met us on some tactics yeah
25 up the edwin so he needs to do that
and now let's check that is Quincy 7 but
this rope here ok and of course the
check and Queen takes but he can he can
give this check and and send exchange
queens hmm
okay if I go here that's not better a
name so Kim so I need to do that he's
got this check and queen d 64 Queen
trade I don't think I have anything
better though yeah it's a very a very
nice position but it's also 40 seconds
I can go to defy you get a get a pawn I
gotta get a peso then get over don't
think you can block me from and always
got the check okay you get the check on
the third-ranked time warning 18 seconds
this is center the real problem in this
position Jay
check check check ah help me he loved me
to win it check just one second yeah and
it's a it's really yeah yeah I mean even
the M I could I could can I can I do
that no yeah I can't even take him this
is much easier even and we don't even
get this this nonsense at the end I just
can take the pawn and then promote yeah
yeah there was no clear away now okay
the rook endgame is a complete when I
mean what else do I want but here there
is no nothing better right plan the
compote so it doesn't find a mate but
this is not not really much of a
difference from a first mate it's a
completely one Luke end game with the
King cut off on the seventh but i only
had this 40 seconds this was the problem
and he could hear i can just oh ok
cannot give the check i thought he could
defend on the third but yeah it's no use
analyze this is winning every which way
yeah i didn't i didn't really have
anything what sir even bit worse the TM
yeah now here this is very good very
good queen bee three is also interesting
the point being that this is in the
position so it cannot move the night but
this this is this is a good end game as
well yeah the various ways so to to get
a good game and well this is this is
this is good enough really but 40
seconds now I maybe you should should
win it but I am it's always a bit tricky
i'm i'm playing 15-minute games in this
session that's once in a while I
accidentally pressed the five-minute
button out of routine and then I family
need to play quicker alright thanks for
watching